Joker, you're on stage. Yes, I can hear
you. Hello, Ivory. How are you? I'm
good.
>> That's good to hear, man. So, the
um the subject is
Jesus is the most high. Yes. So, do you
do you with respect do you believe that
he's higher than his father?
I believe that Jesus and the son I'm
sorry the father and the son are both
the most high together. Together, so
like a equal.
So, you believe all three are equal? Is
that is that right?
Yes, sir. Oh.
Sorry. Yeah, because I got a message
from
>> Take your time. No, that's fine, bro.
That's fine.
Um so, what do you think of John 17:3? I
love that verse. It shows the deity of
the father and the son. So,
the deity of the and the son? Yeah, of
course.
>> Oh, okay. So, um
So, you're you're money is here
straight. You like you believe in one
God, yes?
Yep, I believe in one God who exists as
three persons. That's Trinity.
>> So, in John 17:3, right. So, in John
17:3, who is the the only true God
identified as?
>> In John 17:3, Jesus highlights the
father as the as the true God.
But, he doesn't do it at negation of
himself.
>> true God?
Yeah, there's only one of those. So,
the true God is one.
>> only one, right? Yeah, the true God the
one
one true God, Joker, is multi-personal.
He's the father, the son, and the Holy
Spirit.
>> What does that mean? Yeah, I'm not sure
what that means multi-personal. It means
that the one true God exists as three
distinct persons. The father and the son
and the Holy Spirit are distinct persons
who coexist and share the same divine
essence, [clears throat] the same one
being as the one God.
>> You did
John 4:24 tells us that God is a spirit.
He's not a person. You're a Muslim? No,
I'm not a Muslim. I ex-Jehovah's
Witness, actually. You're an
ex-Jehovah's Witness. Yes, I'm no longer
with the faith anymore. So, what are
you?
>> no. Like I still believe in Jehovah. I
still love Jehovah. I just
um I was excommunicated. What did you
do? Well, I argued with the I argued
with the wrong elder.
>> [laughter]
>> Oh,
you know you're not supposed to argue
with the wrong elder, man.
>> Yeah, well, if something bothers me, I'm
going to challenge it whether he's a
elder or not.
You're not allowed to do that. You're
not allowed to think for yourself and
bring challenges to the elder, man.
Yeah, well, yeah. Well, God gave us free
will and a brain to use, so I decided to
use it. That's good that's a good point.
That's a good point. Okay. I guess he
didn't like that very much and the next
thing you know, I'm out the door. So,
yeah. Oh, man. Well, that's good. I'm
glad you're out out of that. But, you're
still you're still not not in the truth
just yet. So, Yeah, I still Yeah, so
sorry, man. With with with with John
17:3, Yeah. uh really all of John 17
when John 17 like 1 to 5, you have Jesus
talking about how the father glorifies
him
just as he glorifies the father, he has
authority over all flesh and gives
eternal life to all who the father gives
him.
>> All
all this was given by the father, yes?
And this is eternal life that they may
know you, the only true God and Jesus
Christ whom you have sent. So, and then
he goes on to say in verse 5, "Now,
father, glorify me together with
yourself
with the glory that I had with you
before the world was created." Before
the you before creation.
>> Yes. That's
>> demonstrating that Jesus was always
there. He all he he he was he never came
into existence. He was he always existed
just like the father did and shared in
that glory with the father. Would you
say verse 5 is
uh
like
glory was a gift given to Jesus? No.
Like No, it wasn't a gift. You you don't
believe it was a gift given to Jesus.
This is something this is a glory that
he says that he had with the father
before the world existed. So, it's a
glory that he already possessed and he
set it aside to do his earthly ministry
and now is asking for it back.
>> All right, yes, yes.
So, this is how you guys interpret this
verse. It's very good. It's a very good
interpretation.
Thanks. I just read it. Yeah, we we
interpret it a little different. We we
we see it as
that Jehovah gave the gift of glory to
Jesus. But, it says he already had it
before. Yeah, because Jehovah gave it to
him. He was the reflection of Jehovah's
glory. Like technically, Jesus is not
even the glory. He's not
the glory? Yeah, he's a reflection of
God's glory.
Is God's glory finite? I don't know what
that means finite. Does Is there a time
where God's glory does not exist and
then it comes into existence? Well,
Jehovah has always been glory. And
right, so Jehovah's glory is infinite,
right?
>> Infinite glory. Yes, Jehovah's glory
would be yes, infinite, yes. Which would
mean that the radiance or the reflection
of that glory is also infinite, right?
>> No, it was given. It would have to It's
a reflection. So,
technically The glory is always there.
If the Okay, when when does the radiance
or reflection of the glory come into
play? When when when does that come into
existence? When
Jehovah gave it to him. When the I guess
when he created Jesus. Now, but you
you're missing the question.
Yeah, I'm sorry. Yeah, the glory is
infinite.
>> Yeah, glory is Jehovah's infinite with
Jehovah, yes. Okay. So, the glory is
infinite. When does the reflection of
the glory start?
>> When it was created, I guess. When he
decided when Jehovah decided to create
Jesus.
But, if the glory is infinite, wouldn't
the reflection of the glory also be
infinite? The radiance the glory gives
off is also infinite because the glory
is infinite? That he gives off? Yeah,
cuz that's what radiance is like
radiance is something that it comes
from, right? It it is like you know, I
don't even know how to like pours from
or something. I don't know. Yeah, yeah,
like it comes out. Like it's coming out
flowing it's flowing flowing out.
>> Yeah, flowing. Yeah, something like
this? Yeah. Yeah, that would only truly
be on Jehovah's side more because Jesus
was We we believe as well as an
ex-Jehovah's Witness, we were taught to
believe that Jesus was a created being.
I know, but that's wrong. That's the
point. I know you're taught this.
>> Yeah, well, yeah, we're taught this,
yes.
But, according to the scripture, it says
Jesus is not created. Look, let me show
you. Yeah, take take your
[clears throat] time.
Okay. So, you
you're familiar with John 1, obviously.
I'm going to focus on verse 3.
>> Not 1:1, verse 3.
>> Which one? Verse 3.
>> John 1:3? Yes. Uh yeah, I think
I'm going to pull it up. Yeah, yeah,
take your time, bro. John 1:3 over here
on the right. I hope it's big enough.
Can you see it?
>> It says it's small, yeah. Let me do
this.
>> Yeah, all things came into existence
through him and apart from him not even
one thing came into existence what has
come into existence. Exactly.
>> Yeah. So, I
you just read from the New World
Translation, which I I I actually like
that rendering of the verse.
It says
>> Oh, that's through him? Yeah, yeah,
thanks. So, through him all things came
into existence, right? And not one thing
apart from him, not one thing came into
existence that came into existence.
>> Yeah. Everything that has ever come into
existence
in the history of existence came into
existence through Jesus, right?
>> Through Jesus, but not by Jesus, yes.
Whatever. I I don't mind. I don't mind
that. Through Jesus.
>> Yeah, yeah.
This means this means
that Jesus had to already exist. He
always existed to bring everything into
existence that came into existence,
right?
>> Well, well, Revelation 3:14 would debate
that sort of. Nope, Revelation 3:14
actually points to this. Revelation 3:14
says that he's the beginning of the
creation of God, right? Meaning What do
you mean by beginning? Watch this. The
word The word there
is arche. A start. Arche, I don't know
arche what that mean. Arche means source
or or originator.
Yes. Okay. All right. So, look.
>> Yeah.
So, when we go to it, na na na na na, da
da da da da, na na na na na. Arche,
right here it is. The beginning, let me
zoom in on this. Yeah, yeah, I can I can
see it sort of, bro.
>> You can see it? Good. [clears throat]
The arche, the beginning. Now, let's
look at what arche means.
Okay? Beginning, origin, ruler,
authority, principality. Now, let's look
at the summary. Let's see what it says
here. When we go to the lexicon, we go
to the lexicon, let's see how it's used.
All right. Do you see how they bring up
chapter Oh, man. Is it zoomed in on
this?
>> Take your time, bro. You see you see it
in bold black right here? It says
that by which anything begins
to be, the origin, active cause. Right.
So, arche means you're the source of it,
right? You're the originator. You're the
active cause of that thing, right? And
look at the example they give,
Revelation 3:14. Okay, yes. The
beginning of the creation by God.
>> The beginning of the creation of God,
meaning Jesus is
Well, it says Well, yeah, sure. I I
don't mind. It says that Jesus is the is
the origin of the creation. He's the one
He's the active cause, the source of
God's creation. He's the one that starts
it all. He creates It came through him,
yes?
>> Exactly. Exactly, because it came
through him. So, he
>> would be the source here. Well, I I
would
I would argue I would say that with it
calling him the arche, Jesus is the
source cuz he's the active cause by
which things came to be. But, there was
there's something before Jesus here. His
father is before here. No, the father is
not before him. They're together. They
were together. There wasn't a time where
Jesus came into existence because Jesus
it's through him all things came into
existence. Right. Right. Okay.
>> Which means that Jesus is Yeah. Yes.
Which means that Jesus and the Father
have always existed together. Oh, this
is how you guys All right. Now I
understand why you guys interpret this
verse like this. Okay. Mhm. That makes
sense. Yes. Yes.
So, you guys
Is it because of this verse you you
worship Jesus or It's part of it. Yeah.
It's part of it. This is This
>> would be part of it, right?
Yes, because look. Yes. Only You would
agree that only Jehovah, only God,
Jehovah God, almighty God
>> Yeah. is the only one
>> You're right? Who always existed, right?
>> Is eternal? Yes. So, if Jesus is
eternal, then that means that he's one
in essence with Jehovah. He is Jehovah
as well.
>> He is Jehovah? Jesus is Jehovah?
Yes. But we
Okay. Hang on. Hang on. All right. Hang
on.
Now now we've gone into deep waters
here. Okay. Jesus So, let me walk with
you. Let me walk with you. Jesus is
Jehovah.
Jesus is Jehovah. So, but we but you
don't believe Jesus is the Father. Is
that correct?
>> No. Yep. That's correct. So, Jesus is
Jehovah, but Jesus is not the Father.
Can we just Let's
Let's take
the sentence for a second.
Yes.
All right. It's It's a little confusing
for me.
Well, let me let me let me clarify. So,
Jehovah Yeah. So, Jehovah, what the
scripture is showing you This is what
I'm showing you from the scriptures, why
I believe in Jehovah.
>> we read it together. Yeah. Yes, Jehovah.
So, Jehovah
is the source and creator, eternal,
infinite being, right? Only Jehovah is
that. Those are qualities that only
apply to Jehovah, right? So, what we're
seeing here is that those qualities
apply to Jesus. Jesus But no worship But
worship wouldn't apply to Jesus,
brother. Because Exodus 20
Let's Let's go step by step. Step by
step. Exodus 20 2 and 3. You know, the
first It's the first commandment, yeah?
You know the first commandment, right?
Yep.
>> It says, "I am Jehovah your God. You
shall have no other gods besides me."
Now, the Jehovah here is singular. It's
singular, right? In Exodus 20 2 and 3.
Jehovah is always singular.
Jehovah is always singular. Beautiful.
So, how is Jesus
All right. Now we're back to how is
Jesus as Jehovah?
Okay. So, when I say that Jehovah is
always singular, I'm talking about the
name itself, grammatically.
>> Yeah. It's unique. It's unique and
personal, right? It's just It's just a
singular term. It's It's all It's not in
the plural form.
>> you say
would you
would you agree that Jehovah's name is
unique and personal only to him?
Yes, I would agree with that.
So, if I
I'm going to show you that I'm going to
show you that Jesus is called Jehovah.
I'm going to show you that. Okay?
>> Okay. Sure. That would be great.
Okay. So, but let me break down before I
get to that, let me break down what what
I'm what I'm saying. So,
>> Jehovah has these qualities. He's
eternal. He's infinite. He's the
creator. He's the source of everything.
His glory. His God. His all these stuff.
Right. Right. Right. Those qualities are
said of Jesus. Jesus is eternal as we
just saw. He always existed as we saw
from John 1:3 and and Revelation 3:14.
Right?
He's the source of creation along with
the Father. From the Father through the
Son. So, both of them are the source
along with the Spirit, too. We can get
into that later. Are the source of
creation. They are together the source
of creation. From the Father through the
Son by the Spirit. Okay? Now, so when we
have these qualities of Jehovah that are
unique to Jehovah alone, and these
qualities apply to Jesus, that means
that Jesus is Jehovah
along with the Father and the Spirit.
This means that Jehovah is not just one
person.
He's a multitude of persons. He's
multi-personal.
He's a trinity.
That's what the Bible is forcing us to
believe.
We have to believe that Jehovah is three
persons. The Father, the Son, and the
Spirit together are identified as
Jehovah. Well, I Well, Well, I told you
at the start of this conversation that
God is spirit. Jehovah is a spirit.
John 4:24 tells us that Jehovah is
spirit. God is spirit. So, why do you
keep Why do you keep saying that Jehovah
is a person? Well, a person is just an
an agent that has the ability to think,
has a mind, will, emotions,
self-awareness. That's what That's what
personhood
>> The characteristics of a person. What is
the definition of a person? That It
depends on what you're talking about.
So, if you're talking about in what I'm
talking about, we're talking about
philosophically, a person is an agent, a
conscious agent with a mind, will,
emotions, and self-awareness. That's
what personhood
is.
>> a person, brother. That's not the
definition of a person. I need you to
understand what I'm saying. I need you
to No, I'm not sure. I'm not sure I'm
understanding either. When I say person,
I'm not talking in terms of a human
being. An individual human being, yes.
Listen Listen to what Listen to what I'm
saying.
Yeah. Yes.
>> When I say
I'm talking about the philosophical
term, which means an agent with a mind,
will, emotions, and self-awareness.
That's what personhood is, okay? Okay.
Yes. Yes. So, when I say that God is a
person or three persons,
I'm not saying that he's a human being.
I'm saying that he is
Exactly. Exactly.
>> All those attributes. Okay. So,
So, because Jesus has those attributes,
he's worship Jesus, yes? Because Jesus
has the attributes of Jehovah, meaning
he's eternal, infinite, source of
creation, he's worthy of worship because
he's Jehovah.
>> All right. Do you have
So, whatever Whatever Jesus commands you
to do, you you will do?
That's right.
>> Anything? Yeah. Wouldn't you? Anything
Well, yes. Of course. Okay. Okay. Have
you read Mark 12:30? Mark 12:30? Yes.
Mark 12:30.
Yeah.
>> This is a commandment spoken by Jesus.
Yeah. Well, he says that that he's what
the greatest commandment is. That's what
he's doing. No. No. No. No. Mark 12:30,
brother. Yeah. Mark 12:30. He said He
was asked, "What's the greatest
commandment?" and he tells He's just
answering that question. Yeah. What did
he
Do you remember how he answered it?
Yeah. He quoted the Shema. The Lord your
God, the Lord is one. You shall love the
Lord your God with all your heart, mind,
and soul. And you love your neighbor as
yourself.
>> With respect, who's the Lord identified
in Mark 12:30? It's Yahweh. It's
Jehovah. It's Jehovah. That's it. Mhm.
So, Jesus here is commanding you to
worship Jehovah, correct? Yep. So, do
you worship Jehovah? I do. I worship the
Father. I worship the Son. And I worship
the Spirit. Remember this connects back
to Exodus 20 2 and 3. I am Jehovah your
God. You will have no other gods besides
me. Yes? I'm not saying that there's
another god. I I hope you're Pay
attention to what I'm saying, my
brother.
I'm not saying that there's another god
besides Jehovah. I'm saying that Jesus
is Jehovah. Okay. Jesus is All right.
Well, Well,
the first commandment Jehovah is telling
us to worship Jehovah, right?
That's what he's doing there. But I mean
Just so that I can get some
clarification. That's all, man. So, So,
you don't
Do you understand that I'm not saying
that Jesus is another god besides
Jehovah? You believe he's another god. I
don't. Yeah, but we don't even though we
believe Jesus is divine, we don't
worship Jesus. We only worship Jehovah.
How do you honor How do you honor
Jehovah?
How do you honor Jehovah? With deep
respect. What else? Just deep respect.
Honor?
Yeah. How do you honor Jehovah? With
deep respect.
Do you honor him through your worship?
Honor through the worship?
Uh I worship through worship. Would you
say that the way that you honor Jehovah
Do you Would you say that the way that
is is part that worship is part of you
honoring him? Well, honor and worship
are even though they're closely related,
they're two different things. That's
what I'm asking. When you say that you
honor Jehovah, do you honor him through
your worship as well? Is worship
included in the way that you honor? Is
worship included? Worship Worship is
worship. I don't know how else to answer
you, brother. Worship is worship.
>> You You can answer me with a very You
can answer me with a very simple answer
to the question I'm asking.
Is honor Is worship part of the way that
you honor Jehovah, yes or no? A part?
Yes, it is a
part. It is a small part, but it is not
all the part. No, worship is the part.
So, I thank you. So, you And I want you
to fixate on what you just said. You
just said the main part. that one of the
ways You said one of the ways that you
honor Jehovah
is by worshiping him. That's one of the
ways, right?
>> We agreed to part of the way. I got you.
>> all the way. I got you. I got you.
That's good. I see what you're saying.
That's one of the ways that you I got
you. So, watch this. Yeah. Watch what
Jesus says. Mhm.
John 5:23. Yeah. Honor the Father as you
Yeah. I know what it says, brother.
Good. I'm I'm glad you know what it
says. So, you know that you're stuck.
Not really. Because honor technically
doesn't mean worship. Oh, no. Don't
backtrack now.
What am I thinking?
>> It is a part. It is a small I said it
was a small part. It was honor
technically means deep respect. Right
here.
It says that all may honor the Son just
as
>> they honor the Father. So, you're
supposed to honor the same way you honor
the Father, right?
>> Yeah, but worship it's a bit higher.
It's a lot higher than honor.
Wait. Wait. No. You said that worship is
part of your honor, right?
>> Worship is worship. I It's It's Not what
the I'm going to ask Again, I'm going to
give you a chance, Joker. You're now
seeping into dishonesty. I'm going to
ask you the question.
>> Hold on, Joker. I'm going to ask you to
come back
and let's get back on the on the stand
on the platform of honesty. Don't seep
into dishonesty like normal cult members
do. Don't do it. Stay honest.
I'm I'm being honest. You All right,
good. You said earlier that worship is a
part of the way you honor Jehovah,
right?
>> It's the biggest part, yes, okay. Thank
you. So,
the way that you honor Jehovah, the way
that you honor the Father, which part of
that is worship,
you have to give that same exact honor
to the Son, which part of it is worship.
>> Well, that would be going against the
first commandment here because we're
only meant to give worship to Jehovah.
>> No, it wouldn't go against the Look, you
know what
You know what Here it is. Here it is,
Joker. Yes.
>> With your view With your view With your
world view, you're right.
If If Jehovah is only one person, if
he's only the Father,
then this verse is going against the
first commandment, and Jesus is a
blaspheming false prophet. No, it's not
a blasphemy. We don't want to say that
about Jesus. You're right. We don't want
to say that about Jesus. You're right.
Jesus is not a blaspheming false
prophet. Jesus held the absolute proof.
Hold on a second. Yes.
So, Jesus is not going against the first
commandment, right?
No, of course not. Yeah.
Which means the first commandment is
"I am Jehovah. You shall have worship no
other gods besides me."
Now, Jesus says Jesus says the same
honor that you give to the Father, which
includes worship, Hey, hey, hey, hey,
hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey,
hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, I'm
just going to remove you. All right.
Yeah, yeah. Take your time.
I appreciate it. Jesus says, "The same
honor that you give to the Father,
which includes worship, according to
even yourself, that same honor you give
to me, which includes worship. So,
either Jesus is a false blasphemer false
prophet blasphemer
who's who's demanding that you worship
him, or
he is truly worthy of worship because
he's Jehovah, and therefore is this does
not go against the first commandment.
So, which one do you go with? Is Jesus
worthy of your worship, and is Jehovah
therefore He's And he's not a
blasphemer?
Or is he a blaspheming false prophet who
is demanding that you worship him and
going against the first commandment?
Which one do you take? I take That's a
very good question because Deuteronomy
6:4 teaches us that Jehovah is one God
in Deuteronomy 6:4. Jehovah is one God.
>> Which one do you take?
I take that Jesus is to be honored and
Jehovah is to be worshipped. I gave you
two positions.
>> Jesus is to be honored. Jesus is to be
honored, bro.
And Jehovah is to be worshipped. Joker,
I'm going to repeat this to you again.
And if you continue to be dishonest, I'm
just going to kick you out.
>> being dishonest, bro. I'm not lying to
you. I'm not going to up against what's
written. So, let's see. We'll see it
again. Answer this yes or no. Did you
say
Did you say that worship is part of
honor? A small part. I said it was a
small part, yes.
>> I don't care how big the part is. Is it
part of honor or not? No.
>> Get off my stage, you absolute lying
cult member. You left Jehovah's
Witnesses, but you're still cult minded.
Get off my stage. Have fun in hell. May
God have mercy on your soul. Man, it's
good It's a good thing I don't make
those decisions. It's a good It's a good
thing I'm not God. And God, please
forgive me for condemning that man. I
just condemned him. Please forgive me,
Lord. That's not my place. That was me
operating in the flesh.
May God save him and have mercy on him.
But it's a It's It's a It's a good thing
that I don't make these decisions. It's
a good thing. It's It's It's Glory to
God that God is mightier, holier, and
more just than we are, more forgiving
than we are. Cuz if he wasn't, then I'd
be I'd be held bound myself. Incredible.
Just a dumb liar. You guys see what
happens when you deny the deity of
Christ? We show this We showcase this
every single time. We showcase this
every single time. Every time. When you
deny the deity of Christ, you seep into
absurdity,
stupidity, demonic dumbness. You become
tardedry. Demonic stupidity. And then to
say, "No, he didn't say that." At the
end, out of pride,
out of out of the spirit of of lying,
the spirit of deception, couldn't say,
"Yeah, I said that." Get off the stage.
Yeah, I already repented. Oh, man.
Somebody said, "Go grab your rosary,
dog." How do we reach these kids? Islam,
you're on stage.
Oh, [clears throat] what's up? Yeah.
What's up, bro? What's up, man? So, I
have a
a question for you. Can you open
Matthew
2:15?
Does this have to do with Jesus being
the most high God? Yes. You sure? Yes.
So, when I go here, you're going to have
an argument against Jesus being the most
high God? Yes. Okay, bro. I'm trusting
you. If you disappoint me, my patience
is in the red bar. You know, it's not
green anymore. It's in the red bar. So,
it's got to It's got to do it. You said
2 what? Oh,
would Would you Would you allow me to
like ask you about something else? As
long as it has to do with my topic about
Jesus being the most high God, bro. You
can ask me whatever you want along with
that topic. Okay. And
how have you been? What?
>> How have you been? How have I been?
Yes. I've been great.
>> Yeah. Oh, can you open
uh
John
first John
1 1? Does your friend speak English? My
friend?
Yeah, the one who's with you. No, he's
He doesn't. Okay. So, you're like You're
like You're like debating for him? Like
he's telling you what to say, and then
you You'll say it? Um like he's speaking
to me, but like
um
I'm I'm talking to you. Okay. I got you.
All right. What's What's What's his
What's his mother tongue? My mother
tongue? Yeah.
>> Portuguese. Okay. Is that what he's
speaking to you? He's speaking
Portuguese? Yes.
Okay. So, All right, cool. So, what You
said John 1 or first John John 1:1
first. First John 1:1? No, no. John 1:1,
the Gospel of John. Got it. Okay. John
1:1. So, "In the beginning was the word,
and the word was with God, and the word
was God." Yes.
So, here we have the word, right? That's
right.
>> Yes. And the word was is with God,
right?
That's right. Yes. So,
the word that's that is with God
Now, we seen the end of the the verse
that is is like is God, too. So, we have
we have a God with
uh the the word, and the word is also
[clears throat] other God.
So, you have two Gods. Holy taste.
>> No, what we have is two persons who are
both identified as God. They share the
same one nature as God. That's why both
of them can be called God.
So, it's still one God, just two persons
that are together. How
one God is with himself?
Like
like when I say to you, for example,
like you every is with me. How that Do
you understand based on on that that to
me and you are the same thing? Would you
agree that our makeup and our nature is
not like God's nature and makeup?
>> I agree that our nature is not God's
nature, yes.
So,
just how you and I are two different
human beings because we are separated by
time and space and will and mind, when
it comes to God, God's nature is not
divisible like the human nature is
divisible. God's nature is not
divisible. It's one inseparable
indivisible [clears throat] essence,
nature, and the word and the Father and
the Spirit share in this divine essence.
They have the same divine essence and
nature. That's how it can be said that
the word was with God, meaning he's with
a person who is identified as God who
had Right? The Father. And the word was
God, meaning he himself also shared the
same nature that the Father has. Yeah,
but like what What you mean a nature to
be divisible, bro? What you mean with
that? Like Like the Like you know how
there's There's more than one human
being?
Like there's a human nature. The human
nature is shared between
more than one human being, right?
There's There's different human beings,
right?
>> Yeah, sure. But there's only one divine
being.
There's not
>> how do you know that? Cuz there's only
There's only one God. Yeah, but this is
what you're saying. This is what you're
saying.
>> I I can I can claim that the scripture
is not saying that. So, you believe
You believe there's more than one God? I
believe that the scripture is saying
that. Okay.
>> Do you want to see?
Do you want to see? Just really quick
cuz you're you're moving I think you're
No, I'm not moving. I'm moving because
if you have two
Just really quick. Do you and I Do you
and I agree that there's only one God?
Do you and I agree that there is only
one God? Yeah, I believe there is only
one God, but I believe your scripture is
not saying that. I know that's what you
believe. And so, I'm showing you from my
scriptures that it says there's only one
God,
and it identifies multiple persons as
being the one God, the word
Jesus, the Father, and the Spirit.
>> Okay. Let's Let's see the the only one
God.
The first argument I I I gave you was
that the one God was with another,
right? And if you go to verse 18, you
see that
uh this is this is even more clear cuz
the the verse 18 is saying that
uh God was not
was never known to people
and that the
um
the begotten I I think that's the word.
I don't know how is the verse in English
but like the the begotten God that was
with the Father he became known to
people. So you have one God that is
known
and you have other God that's not known.
You understand what I mean? How there is
just one God, bro? If one is known and
the other is not known, you have two
Gods. Polytheist. Can you break down
what I said? Yeah, you said that
you have only one uh
nature and
in in God and stuff and you said that
like human beings are different from God
because they are their their essence is
divisible and stuff but like um
I I wouldn't say that that our essence
is divisible is not the case. Our
essence is only like
present in one
>> I'm saying? Can you break down what I'm
saying? Please break down what I
said. What did I say about God and his
essence? You said that God's essence is
not divisible.
That's what you said. What else did I
say? You said that our God's essence is
not like human essence. That's what you
said. Isn't it?
Watch your head. Take care of it.
>> [clears throat]